what we want to think about first when
we're starting off the semester is
religious studies as a discipline itself
so I would think that what I'm going to
say to some of you will strike you as a
bit common sensical and you might say
why am i waking yourself well it's to
avoid confusions that will come up later
though to avoid the kind of confusion
that will show up over and over again if
we don't get them addressed begin it so
religious studies as a discipline it's
only been around as a discipline for
about a hundred years yeah and it really
didn't take them off until you know a
few decades ago a lot of times when
people were studying religion they would
study religion from a particular
perspective so usually when we talk
about teaching religion or learning with
religion what we meant was learning a
religion and we meant learning that from
within the perspective of that religion
being committed so you would go to you
know if you're Catholic you would go to
CCD and CCD they're probably not going
to teach you about you know the whole
variety of religions and they're making
some presuppositions about the truth of
Christianity and that the Catholic
Church would be you know the best place
to go for that if you go to a mantras
you know you're gonna be learning about
Islam and odds are you'll be learning
about one particular way of looking at
it because you know we tend to
specialize in that way
and it's gonna be from a committed
perspective if you go to Hebrew school
odds are they're gonna have you reading
you know Hebrew texts and what would be
the earliest Hebrew texts we've got our
hands on the Torah yeah why would they
be doing that so that you could read
them as they believer religious studies
a little bit different we're studying
religion from a not necessarily
committed perspective
so one of the features of religious
studies that I want to point out is
let's put it like this there's no
commitment required or presuppose and if
we're doing it well this doesn't mean
that you can't have you know some sort
of religious belief practice coming into
it as a learner as a teacher as a
researcher but you can't bracket it you
put it on hold
so that it doesn't interfere with what
it is that you're trying to study
because you know if you think about it
if you're if you're not just studying
one particular religion but a variety of
different religious groups and
traditions you're generally having to
approach other people's views yeah if
you've already decided from the very
beginning I'm only gonna listen to what
I think is relevant important true then
it's very hard to hear other people
especially when you know that they
disagree with you on some some
fundamental points so religious studies
is going to be different than something
like theology theology if you were to
study then it's going to be you know
Christian theology or Muslim theology or
Jewish theology or Buddhist theology you
know we can there's different words for
these sorts of things but we use this
category theology to talk about
something where there is a a particular
commitment so everybody's clear about
that right this is it doesn't mean that
you can't have commitments of your own
or Express those those sort of views
that your own personal experiences have
somehow become irrelevant as we're going
through these chapters it just means
that you don't take them as being how
should we put it being determinative you
know what's going on you might say that
we we stopped short of certain questions
you say what a religious people
these different groups actually thanked
each why do they think so we don't say
are they right we don't worry about that
so much that would be getting into
theology so that's one important
connection another thing is that
religious studies is multidisciplinary
and often misspelled words so looking at
them from time to time so I misspelled
something let me know because I don't
want to you know just leave it up here
incorrect for the whole class period so
we say something a multi-disciplinary
what are we it's a fancy word if you
guys encountered this before so I'm
going to say interdisciplinary is that a
term that you run across what do you
think we mean when you're discipline
there's there's some yeah you know this
that's a good point that there has to be
some sort of rigor you can't count
anything whatsoever as religious studies
there has to be some sort of studies
element it somebody else have their hand
yeah
very good and now each of those is
associated with its own particular kind
of rigor and brings a perspective to it
so when you study things from an
economics perspective you're not
studying it from a literary perspective
and in literature it's not the case that
anything goes that every interpretation
is just as good as any other one you
know just ask a literature professor
about that historical interpretation is
going to be a bit different than a
sociological interpretation and they
might draw each other some of the fields
that religious studies has been drawn
are themselves rather multidisciplinary
like geography
that's a multidisciplinary field history
you know there's there's different
divisions of cultural history yeah
economic history legal history what do
you think just sort of you know guessing
off the top of your head what would you
say that the the fields that religious
study would draw on would most likely be
yeah history plays a big part in
religious studies you know to start our
textbook is from a historical
chronological perspective that's the
overarching order that they're we're
using for what else yeah okay now when
you say science that's that covers we
should always talk about the sciences
because there's no one single thing well
what are the sciences
yeah yeah we're not really worried about
that we're not we're not taking a stand
on whether this is true or not at this
point a lot of the way you're talking
about would be a philosophy of religion
oftentimes when science trades over into
religion it does bad science you know
when you see natural scientists or
neurobiologists trying to talk about
their religious impulse when you start
probing it it often turns out to be
rather questionable but that takes us a
bit out of the field of religious
studies as such but some of the sciences
are involved what are the other of the
sciences or some of the actions
disciplines gonna call the sciences you
guys are probably associating Sciences
like physics chemistry biology
those are Natural Sciences what are
other sciences that we have social yeah
here in the States we call them social
sciences in French and German these are
called the human sciences because they
have to do with the human subject so
what would those who could yeah whatever
yes political science is a important
part of it brother social sciences study
think about the ones that we have
available here at Marist yeah
and as you'll see about the why what
else any other as I come to mind I don't
think we have a specialization in it
here but but anthropology do we have it
as a major economic often called the
dismal science what else didn't fit so
cover the gamut of the sciences there oh
there's one other you can call it a
social science I suppose it really could
connects together a lot of other fields
archaeology quite important anthropology
sometimes it ends up blending in a bit
with sociology anthropology is literally
the study of human beings on purpose
what is it that that makes us human what
is it that's essential to us what it's
turned into is largely a set of
different disciplines that are connected
with each other like cultural
anthropology where you're doing you know
examinations of this culture so you
might go into for example an old Iraqi
walled city and look at the culture of
the people there and try to do some sort
of narrative of what's going on and you
might actually draw on sociological or
psychological concepts and techniques
these all tend to blend into each other
what else we've got the natural / the
social science of this we've got his
what else might be important for
religious studies yeah yeah you know
philosophy continuing generally
philosophy on religion right now not so
much worries about what's what's the you
know science versus religion stuff but
things about the nature of religious
language or the role that narrative
plays in our understanding of the world
what else might fit in there yeah that
words like getting into the humanities
history philosophy literature I'm gonna
I'm not going to try to summarize all
the different ones but let's just say my
merits as well
religious art plays a very important
usek often plays a role in ritual so you
notice that you've got all these
different perspectives all I should
probably with sticks up there as well
any one of those may be useful for
religious studies yeah the person who's
doing religious studies is kind of a
jack-of-all-trades
what what differentiates him or her from
among the researchers is that he or she
is primarily focused on studying
religion and spends an awful lot of time
you know actually delving into religious
texts through the gist narratives you
know what it is that the people in this
particular religious group believe feel
do what their history is so it's kind of
hard to put a finger up exactly on what
is religious studies it's it's easier to
do that with something like psychology
although any one of these other
disciplines once you start digging into
it how many of you by the way how many
of you are majoring in any of these so
the and you're going through your
studies you may think that you know
exactly what psychology or political
science is just go to another school and
see how it's taught there and see what
their divergences are and how the
instructors can see that there and
you'll realize that although there is a
unity to each one of those fields it's a
lot harder to define than we originally
presented as so you know why do they
give you all this just to give you an
idea of what you're getting into
there's a number of other things that
are connected with religious studies
that I want to touch on before we
actually look at the text the next thing
I want to talk about we can call this
basic religious so we would say
diversity what do we mean we mean that
not everybody is on the same page not
everybody's coming from the same
perspective you know think about those
of you who studied in world religions
how many major world religions would you
say their arms 5 15 any other guesses
that's a big range 5 to 15 minutes of it
depends on how we consider major you
know where the cutoff is notice already
we've got some divergences of what we're
calling you know significant or major or
relevant even within a particular
religious tradition does everybody on
the same page
do all Muslims believe exactly the same
thing about the role of the hadith
or who should pull the authority within
within the religious community no it
wasn't already a big divergence between
the two major groups Sunni and Shia and
then if you're a Sunni also knees you
know see things exactly the same way
know there are different legal schools
different ladies were practicing yet the
Shiites are spread out over a number of
different groups Twelver Shiites are not
the same thing as seven or Shiites are
not the same things Druze and we can do
the same thing for any other group do
all Buddhists believe the same thing
exactly and we can go on and on like
that so meat there's a diversity of
religions and here's where we actually
get into what you could call the issue
of truth claims how do we deal with the
fact that there are other people who see
things very differently than us given
whatever you know perspective you have
in the whole yeah there there's in the
philosophy of religion and theology they
often talk about three main attitudes
well if they're all isms
so we've got these these three different
positions there's actually more than
let's start with pluralism and you can
think of this as sort of a spectrum
falernum ISM all the way to exclusivism
to the word exclusive what do you think
what does that make you think yeah yeah
that's a great way to play if you're an
exclusive all the rest I'm going to over
generalize a little bit but I want to
sort of stress this all the rest of my
deadline that best they may participate
in just a glimmer the truth the
correctness that is offered by the one
true faith the one correct perspective
all the rest of them no good so you know
what would be examples of this Christian
fundamentalism which by the way is not
if you want to be strict about it is not
the same thing that the media calls
fundamentalism they use the word in a
very loose and sloppy way actual
Christian fundamentalists believe that
there are certain fundamentals of the
Christian faith that you have to believe
or you're not a Christian and that you
can't hold fellowship with anybody who
doesn't accept those fundamentals so
that would be the great example of an
exclusivist point of view wouldn't it
Islamic what they call AMA
fundamentalism I prefer the term radical
Islam or totalitarian Islam it would be
another example of this
a lot of the smaller groups that tend to
be you know apart from the rest of the
society separating themselves out will
have this sort of perspective let's go
to the other pluralist what does that
term that's a relatively new word I
think it's probably about as old as me
it's not good I'm old and compared some
new Turks I'm twice your age I'm 43 but
in terms of you know language that's not
very but it's not been around for a very
long time one of the meanings it arose
not the line until I'm like mixing
together that would be more like what we
call syncretism or synthesis blending
things together this would be something
that somebody could in fact believe from
from the perspective of certain faith
commitments but they'd be believing it
about other other religions you remember
this expression there's you know many
paths but one goal that's sort of that's
an example of what the kenneth pluralism
that a lot of scholars meaning they
resist her there's one let's call it 1
through goal many paths so
certain perspectives within Hinduism
would would fit this you know there's
for example a lot of a lot of
practitioners of Hinduism are worshipers
of Vishnu and that's the aspect under
which the divine is is understood and
Vishnu has appeared in the form of a
number of avatars a number of ways in
which he became manifest on earth again
if you actually look at the literature
they're not all things like you know
Krishna guys in India a lot of my sites
are willing to say yeah Jesus was was an
avatar Vishnu a form in which missioner
took to go help out those people in the
Middle East doesn't usually fly to all
the Christians Hindus say that sort of
thing some of them may even go so far as
to say Mohammed was dragged to Muslims
nuts but that's a good example of this
sort of pluralist point of view it's all
really the same everyone's got their own
little path or you society has got its
own path but they're all equally good so
we've got something here in middle
inclusive ism what do you think that
would be if it's somehow men between
these two yeah I was gonna say like you
get part of the religion but you see
other possibilities
go through it but you're kind of open to
it yeah let's call it one truest
perspective other perspectives are more
or less true so what would be some
examples of this again if you think that
Islam and its attitudes towards other
other religions in particular towards
Judaism Christianity and if we leave
aside you know sort of very hardcore
with male Sunni interpretations like
Wahhabism or deal bond you know schools
and we think about the vast majority
what'll they say about Christians and
Jews well their peoples of the boy they
have a form of Revelation it's not as
good as the Quran but it's still you
know it's not chopped liver it's it's
it's not totally one it's at least on
the way towards and this is the way that
a lot of schools of Buddhism will not
only talk about other religions but even
other schools of Buddhism there's like a
whole hierarchy do you want the really
great stuff it's here this is the truest
message but you know there's people who
are getting this message and that's not
bad it's better than nothing at all that
would be inclusive is a lot of a lot of
Christian churches are examples of
inclusiveness churches where they'll say
well you know we'd go to this one
because we think that we actually have
the best understanding of these things
but in a word we're willing to grant
that other Christians are onto something
they just you know they don't have a
media you see how that's quite different
than the exclusivist
interpretation
now if you want to do religious studies
which of these can you hold which can
you make sure the classroom width and
then sort of bring in defense yeah they
could get world's matter of fact that
might actually encourage you to seek out
information about other other faiths you
know could you be an exclusive us well
you could but you could only study the
chapter belonging to your particular
group and you know one day or the rest
of the time you became fuming there and
thinking this is all bs by the way
exclusivism is not only possible from a
religious perspective think about the
spectrum of of atheism somebody who is
you know decided you know that the
religion really isn't true
you can be a secular exclusivist as well
you can also guess you know like a
secular Crusader oh crap the terrible
stuff we should never study any of this
you're not going to get much out of a
religious studies class if you're coming
with that sort of pointed yeah that's
not the entire spectrum available for
phrase their equivalents like inclusive
is you know religion may offer something
to to its practitioners some religions
may be better or worse in terms of these
things do you think this is all the
possible perspectives
there's the way a lot of people present
this is that this is all you could
possibly yeah yeah your excuse me I'll
be opinion like not necessarily
exclusive yeah I mean you're just sort
of unthinkingly exclusivist you know
it's possible to be exclusive from some
principle after like having thought
things through and say look this is just
you know I looked at all the evidence
and the data this is just where I had
nothing there are there are some very
brilliant people out there fit into the
exclusivist mode yeah could there be
something right like maybe your
pluralist but like there's one specific
oh that's interesting
there there are many paths but they're
not all equally valid some of them are
actually you know bad paths yeah there's
there's a discussion about about
pluralism yeah they they call this
divergent pluralism so let me put this
down
yeah and why is it divergent because
they don't say that there's one hole not
for example if you're a very very
traditional Theravada Buddhist and you
haven't sort of you know turn the
conception of Nirvana into something
very much like have an immature it's a
lot of Buddhist it's done historically
the Christian conception of happening
and the Buddhist conception of Nirvana
don't we actually look like the same
thing a lot of people want to be a
blonde them together as well and
everybody's after bliss or the movies
after transcendence but maybe the
different religions are actually after
different things and if that's the case
then maybe some of them actually have
that error and worse you know goals with
their image there if there is a religion
how many of you seen that that movie
Chronicles of Riddick
recently I have you've seen it I mean it
came out like in the last what eight
years it's a fiction movie it's science
fiction right there's this this religion
of the neck world mongers and it's
basically a religion worshiping death
and they go around they take over
planets and they kill everybody or turn
them into slaves and they're very creepy
kinds of kinds of people but imagine
that was an actual religion here on
earth it would be quite possible for a
Hindu or a Christian who otherwise is
willing to say yeah there's a lot of
different paths on there they're going
different places a lot of those places
are pretty good to say yeah that one I
think is that's a bad one we shouldn't
you know we shouldn't advocate that and
say oh the herd of their head
the same thing that's another
possibility as a matter of fact I think
that this is actually in some respects a
bit more respectful the distinctiveness
of people's religious traditions to be
willing to recognize that not everybody
is doing exactly the same thing or not
everybody is basically aiming for the
same thing but doing it in a worse job
edit than than one of a particular group
I belong to these are these are workable
options
another possibility that they talk about
is what's called relativism you guys may
remember this from your philosophy
classes you'll remember that term
usually teachers want to disabuse you of
it right away be the relativist what was
the relativism and it's in the word
relative what about your family
truth perspectives are all relative to
your you know your particular point of
view so you have your truth and I have
my truth and even though they contradict
each other they're both equally true
just your truth is true for you and my
truth is true for me and maybe also for
him because he you know he happens to
see things the same way but you know
your truth is good for you too
everything is equally valid within that
you can adopt that kind of perspective
too but it tends to make it hard to make
judgments other than I mean you know
your perspective within that bubble so
these are kind of the gamut and the I
want you to think about this think about
where you would actually fit into this
and whether you're happy with being in
the slot that you're in you can move
from one to the other and
it's important to know where you're
going from as you're moving into the
field of religious studies the last
thing that I want to touch up before we
look at the tags so we call a religious
literacy and that's something that
religious studies should provide you if
you're actually putting in the work that
you're expected to put in religious
literacy is a variety of what we would
call cultural literacy so you know let
me pose a really easy question it's not
C's good or bad yeah funny you know how
do you have you met any Nazis lately
they did not see you like knock over
your mailbox or believe you and you're a
kid so how do you know that the Nazis
were bad not everybody actually thinks
they're thankfully those who don't are
in the minority these days but how do
you know how did you arrive at that set
so quickly because we know yeah you know
that's part of cultural literacy I have
known people who have given pre-tests in
like humanities classes in certain parts
of the United States where it would
include questions like who was Adolf
Hitler and people we know the answer to
that imagine if you didn't know that
trying to make sense out of a lot of
things that people would talk about I
don't let you know my ethics classes I
don't let people use not see examples
anymore because they're two E's that
everybody you know is against the Nazis
everybody knows they're supposed to be
against
I want them to actually pick harder
examples because that's become so so
much a part of what you call the the
network of concepts that we have our
veteran disposal let me give you a
slightly tougher one Alexander the Great
what what did he do exactly
why was he an important guy some of the
Mediterraneans parts of the eastern
Mediterranean what else
anyhow come to he actually took over
large parts of the Middle East in
non-public Middle East where by the way
he's often known as Alexander the terror
because he destroyed the Persian Empire
the Greek polytheistic religion on
people who weren't really uh you know
into that sort of thing like for example
the Jews at that time he actually made
it as far as India and then his troop
said that's enough
kind of tired of watching around with
this guy for 20 years
well i'm dinah marcher allen and fight
people now how did you actually know
anything about Alexander the Great
well because you possess some degree of
cultural literacy and if you notice
something about Alexander the Great then
you might also know something about
somebody else who really admired him
like a lot of people did let's say
Julius Caesar dude you guys are all
familiar I suppose with that guy
cultural literacy is really like knowing
a bunch of different things that are
connected with each other and being able
to draw those connections and when
you've got a certain critical mass when
you've got certain structures in place
when you get new information you're able
to draw analogies you're
figure out where things fit in with each
other you're able to make sense of the
conversations and educated people are
having with each other you can follow
what the talking heads on the batter
opinion programs are referring to if you
don't have that you're kind of that loss
when it comes to some important things
yeah and you know you can talk about all
sorts of other kinds of literacy as well
right so what we're talking about
religious literacy we're talking about
matters of religion
yeah and how religions grew and how
they're connected with each other who
the important people were like you know
here here's a good example
Jews have a Martin Luther King Day a few
days ago right everybody knows why the
guy was important I think what did he do
come on yeah that's that's what we
identify him with what was his job what
was his day job says organizing marches
yeah exactly
he was a religious figure the civil
rights movement was primarily a
religious movement within the United
States it had a whole rhetoric King
speeches if you read it
those are biblical references and he's
making and reworking and some of them
are to other people who like John
Winthrop you know the city on a hill
idea that played a very important role
in American politics what denomination
did King belong to anyone no was he a
Catholic was he Greek Orthodox
was the Presbyterian was the Baptist
well it wouldn't have been Southern
Baptists but he was Baptist yeah no he
actually studied something some Lutheran
figures in seminary but he was a Baptist
yeah knowing something about that tells
you something about what went on here
and how the churches were organized
that's part of religious literacy this
class should provide you with a lot of
those other dots that you don't
currently have now why does this become
a big issue these days and I can spend a
lot of time on this book why is this
important
I mentioned last class a lot of people
thought that maybe modernization
religion should fade away as a religion
faded away or is it still extremely
important for us within the world well
more than half the people in the world
today are committed to one religion
another so it's going to be important
just for that does religion play a role
in politics to play a role in economics
to play a role in international policy
making yeah we learned this the hard way
the way things went in Iraq and not
knowing a lot of people didn't
ambulators literacy not knowing about
the difference between Sunnis and
Shiites and how to negotiate things why
do you think that you guys didn't get a
lot of this in middle high school a lot
of this information
yeah it's all kind of a touchy stuff you
know people like mature enough to really
appreciate it
that's interesting
so there's two different things there
it's it's it's touchy-feely stuff okay
so so listen artisodes music so it's
history really when you get down to the
COS their divergent interpretations we
teach those things and then you said
people think that you're not mature
enough that's that's really interesting
to say because how do you develop
maturity it's only by actually doing
things by engaging with things if you
cut people off from stuff you actually
prevent them from being able to mature
in certain important respects a lot of
people don't want to talk about religion
in particularly in public schools but
even in in parochial schools in part
because they may be poorly informed
about it they may be lacking in
religious literacy or there's this
feeling that look we can't be teaching
religion right this we'll talk about
this a bit more in the First Amendment
we're not supposed to have a national
engine not supposed to establish a
religion here and there teaching
religion like you know if you do the you
know a class on fine head in English
class Bible as literature aren't you
teaching religion aren't you
proselytizing them aren't you like
enforcing some sort of religious mindset
onto people now I'm gonna take a
religious studies perspective where you
say well we're interested in one of
these people actually think what if one
of these texts means not in who's right
or who's wrong as a matter of fact
there's a big difference between
teaching religion and teaching about
teaching about a religion you're not
actually making some sort of faith or
perspective you're not requiring anybody
to believe anything other than you know
what the documents say like you know the
Puritans actually did show up here and
they actually did believe these things
and here's what you know what their
attacks were but you're not actually
saying you have to believe what the
Puritans taught that would be teaching
the budget and the Supreme Court made a
rigid distinction between this quite a
while ago back in case called Abington
Township
versus Shemp in 1963 and the thing they
said it's very important to teach about
religion in school because without it
you don't understand history you don't
understand
human development you don't understand
the world that we live in you're cut off
from a lot of other people that belong
to you know religious groups within this
this incredibly diverse society you can
add to that that if you're going to be
globally involved or globally engaged
you need to know quite a bit about
religions in order to be able to meet
people where they are you don't believe
in anything that they believe you don't
have to buy into any of it but you need
to know about it it's much more
important to understand than to worry
about agreement and that's that's what
religious studies is about that's
supposed to provide you ultimately what
we call religious literacy